Another really important note is that you use the subject line.
So, don't leave the subject blank...
...because receiving an email from someone without a subject line...
...is an email that might go unread.
So, include a subject line, whether it be, thank you,...
...or whether it be checking the status of whatever it is you are checking the status of.
Make sure that you include a subject line.
A formal email never includes things like hey, what's up, what's going on,...
...you want to make sure that you are as formal as possible.
So, it's Dear Mr. such and such or Dear Ms. such and such.
You want to keep a paragraph format.
You want to use correct punctuations and grammar...
...and you want to be sure that you sign off.
So, sign off with the appropriate sign off.
Kind regards from, yours sincerely, yours truly...
...and be sure to include your first and last name.
So those are just a few tips on formal versus informal emails.